à l'issu des 10 minutes la journée
défense et citoyenneté est obligatoire
pour tous les jeunes citoyens français
une journée parfois exceptionnelle le
thème mémoire combattante et des
conflits sport mémoire et engagement
elle était organisée dans le cadre du
Plan ambition armée jeunesse du
ministère des armées en partenariat avec
la mairie de plaisir il y a deux
objectifs en fait il y a un objectif
qu'on retrouve dans chaque JDC qu'on
fait en dehors de nos sites habituels
c'est celui de bien travailler ce lien
entre la jeunesse et la nation de
aspect effectivement c'était celui de
venir lier cette JDC à la thématique
sportive parce que c'est une année
olympique parce que c'était aussi de
l'année de la Coupe du monde de rugby en
France c'est aussi le lien qui a été
fait notre partenaire l'Office national
des combattants et victimes de guerre
qui est détenteur un peu des aspects
mémoriels de l'histoire militaire de
France a avec nous souhaiter développer
une exposition sur le thème du rugby et
de la mémoire celle d'ancien rugbyman
ayant combattu pendant les deux conflits
mondiaux on veut faire passer le message
des valeurs du sport mais en même temps
des anciens combattants c'est-à-dire que
le sport comme le rugby c'est des
valeurs de dépassement de soi de valeurs
d'amitié de groupe c'est toute cette
mémoire en fait à la fois de sportifs de
haut niveau pour un grand nombre et
d'anciens combattants qu'on veut faire
euh connaître aux jeunes et leur montrer
que les valeurs qu'avaient nos anciens
il est intéressant de les étudier et de
les acquérir ou de les conserver pour
ceux qui les ont déjà pour cela les
jeunes Plaisirois ont pu participer à
plusieurs activités mais en sport et
histoire j'ai trouvé ça très intéressant
parce que ça change des journées qu'on a
l'habitude de nous dire c'est-à-dire où
on est juste assis et qu'on écoute
pendant toute la journée j'en ai appris
sur le rugby moi je connaissais pas du
tout l'histoire du rugby surtout je
savais pas que les rugbyman avait été
mobilisé pendant la guerre ou ce genre
de chos on a appris vraiment beaucoup de
choses aujourd'hui sur bah l'état la
société la défense à la fin de la
journée des certificats de participation
à la journée défense et citoyenneté ét
dcné il s'agit d'un justificatif
obligatoire pour s'inscrire à un examen
ou concours organisé par les autorités
françaises